I know how important winning is to Tom
they're gonna play it off on camera and
everything but they're gonna be pretty
intense about it ladies and gentlemen we
welcome in Wes Welker to give some
insights on the match powered by Cisco
WebEx Wes it's great to see you man
absolutely thanks for having me who do
you think is gonna take this match more
seriously Peyton or Tom I'm sure there's
gonna be a lot of talk back and forth
I think Peyton's gonna govern the the
talking trash and he's got to bring some
money into it because once Tom gets down
like that's when you're able to kind of
really get them how many times have you
played against Tom and Baton probably
around like 20 times each which player
do you think will have the longest drive
on the first team to start the whole
match
because he's used to getting off the
good starts who do you have your money
on Tom's probably the better golfer but
he hasn't been playing as much where I
know Peyton's probably been playing a
lot I don't know if I'm Tom or Peyton
like I'd be I don't know I think it
would have picked a of course where you
can at least find your ball how you
played medalists before this golf course
in Florida I have like really really
cool like it's kind of edged out there's
some greens that are really really tough
you can lose it quite a few balls around
there that would be hilarious if either
one of those guys has to go into a into
the pond to retrieve their ball yeah
well look out for the Gators I'm
expecting them to hit it for right and
far left because that's usually what
they do when they play with me Peyton's
most famous audible is Omaha Omaha
wasn't an audible or anything who's just
had to do with the snap count yeah I
there's no telling how much money that
guy's made off the field off of Omaha
Omaha how would you get under Peyton's
skin and how would you get under Tom's
skin that's where you get her to
Peyton's stand as to embarrass from when
you least expects it how do you ever
gotten Peyton we were doing a Sports
Illustrated shoot we set up a camera we
made up this deal that yeah we're not
doing jerseys we're gonna they want us
to do it just pads but nothing on
underneath
I'm not doing that like what are we
doing this is Sports Illustrated